ahora veamos cómo es por dentro el
interruptor de palanca con un polo y
doble tiro tiene un polo este y dos
tiros lo que significa que podemos hacer
conexión en tres distintos lugares en
este interruptor y así controlar la
corriente en dos circuitos entonces
tomamos el destornillador de relojero
para abrir la cubierta del interruptor
muy bien entonces este es el interior de
nuestro interruptor de palanca ahora
veamos cómo es por dentro hay dos
contactos
aquí tiene un polo y dos tiros eso
significa que cuando el interruptor está
abierto permite que la corriente fluya
en un circuito y cuando está cerrado
permite que la corriente fluya por el
otro circuito o simplemente cierra el
circuito puedes ver que aquí hay un
pequeño martillo de plástico que empuja
el resorte y así al presionar la palanca
el martillo hace que el resorte sea
empujado hacia abajo contra este
contacto de cobre y eso hace el cambio
de corriente entre cada uno de los tiros
entonces lo que el interruptor hace
básicamente es abrir y cerrar el
circuito entre este lado y este lado y
entre este lado y este lado ahora
observa atentamente podrás ver ese
pequeño contacto de cobre moviéndose de
arriba a abajo
creo que estas piezas están hechas de
aluminio parece que el resorte es de
acero la palanca tal vez sea de acero en
chapado con níquel el resorte está
conectado a un contacto de cobre la
cubierta yo creo que está hecha de
plástico abs y tal vez está hecha en un
molde que es de plástico abs inyectado
ahora puedes ver aquí hay unos pequeños
barrotes que encajan en los agujeros de
la tapa de la cubierta
ahí están
si colocamos la tapa puedes ver que
encaja perfectamente
y estos pequeños barrotes funcionan como
clavos pasan por esos agujeros y para
poner a la tapa en su lugar tal vez lo
que hacen es tomar un pedazo de acero
caliente y presionan sobre los barrotes
ahora como estos son de plástico se
derriten y mantienen la tapa en posición
y así es como la tapa del interruptor de
palanca con un polo y doble tiro se
mantiene en su lugar la cubierta parece
ser de un molde de plástico inyectado
ahora recapitulando presionamos la
palanca y eso hace que la corriente
eléctrica cambie entre el polo este es
el polo y los dos tiros el contacto que
es el polo siempre está conectado y
estos son los dos tiros cuando presionas
la palanca la corriente cambia entre los
dos tiros y el polo